flipped with uh 95 did he  that was oh  cc6 c6 c6 is the movement after knight  dicks i reckon it's six here and then  now we are shielding the pawn i think  danny the correct move here was to take  wasn't it yeah definitely  take on c5  because then if the king goes here we  check the pawn down here if the king  goes here then we have this move  but the crucial move is king f6  indeed but but enough you play king i  just go back and then here yeah  but he did this the wrong way in the  time pressure  and now he's paying the price that's a  shocker  oh boy that is gonna sting  that is gonna sting  well that's  that's a big win for for prague  yeah i mean  any king who is good but k7 is the  cleanest  king f5 is also very good keeping the  king 2 diagonal 2 squares diagonal from  the